hi there writing do we need to write I
don't write very much when I learn
languages but when I was learning
Chinese I wrote a lot to learn 4,000
characters I mean I I took the position
that I had to write the characters out
longhand the first thousand I wrote many
many times each one I had to hold my own
sort of special system for learning them
and I continued to write it to write
them I had to write for the final exam
so it was a studying Mandarin was a
full-time job I learned about 4000
characters I wrote a lot obviously I
wrote a lot of French because I studied
in France for three years I was a
university student there we had all
kinds of essays to write in French but
all the other languages I don't write
them hardly at all I write a bit on the
computer I've written some in Japanese
occasionally in Spanish with Russian I
used the phonetic keyboard because I'm
just not I don't want to devote the time
to learning to training myself to type
Russian because I don't write often
enough in Russian to justify
investing that time so now I'm reading
Korean and I keep on making the same
mistakes like instead of if it's on you
know these little symbols it's you know
it's either a sound or an R sound that I
mistake the OO sound for an R sound or a
sound for an O sound and you know and I
look at it and I should have been able
to tell the meaning but I can't because
I gave it the wrong sound and I mean I
remember in Russian for the longest time
if I saw a word that began with the
Russian R which looks like a P if I
looked it up in the dictionary I would
look up under P rather than R so it's
very hard to get the the new writing
system engrained in our brains and I'm
quite convinced that writing is a very
good thing to do why don't I do it
because I'm essentially lazy I learned
for fun I have so much time to spend and
I started trying to write the Korean
I've had several stabs at it I just
can't bring myself to do it because I'm
so much more interested in listening and
reading
in acquiring more words so I think it's
a matter of choice it depends how much
time you have I know there are people
who say I'm gonna learn 2,000 words and
I'm gonna really learn them thoroughly
and I'm gonna write them and I'm gonna
write sentences
I'll use my Anki deck and I get a nail
of stuff down and I'm not that we
motivated I think if I have if I really
nail down 2,000 words I still won't be
able to understand Kim Jung Hwa's
podcast I still won't be able to
understand much of what I read on in the
Korean newspaper so I'm not so fast so
that's why I don't write but I don't
necessarily recommend that people
shouldn't write I think writing is a
great way to get started in expressing
yourself because you have more time to
think about it but here again typically
I prefer to speak rather than to write
because the trouble with writing is you
leave all your mistakes out there for
other people to look at when you speak
they kind of flow by so for example I
had someone ask me in Russian about
something having to do with how you
navigate in our linked library to find
English content you know depending how
do you find out whether it's American or
British and stuff so I did a screencast
which I narrated in Russian then I sent
him a note in English and I wrote it in
English and I said here's a little file
which will explain to you how to do this
on our site because somehow it almost
embarrasses me to write in Russian
because I know that I'll make mistakes
whereas when I speak and I make mistakes
it doesn't bother me however probably
it's a good thing to write for people
who have the time and the perseverance
to do so but our mom is attracted by
other stuff and and so even listening to
Kim Young has I've now really worked at
the first two transcripts I mean it's
very difficult lots of words lots of
words for which the dictionary doesn't
even give me a an answer you know so
lots of work but you know I was on my
stepper listening to it and reading
through it and I get the rhythm of the
language it's so great I'm still
convinced that if I persevere with that
I will have a better sense and feel for
the language and I find that already
just by listening to his podcast my
spoken Korean has improved and even
though I've been
neglecting my Korean other than
listening to his podcasts often without
a transcript often only understanding
20% when I spoke to my Korean tutor he
remarked on how much better
I was speaking so so yeah I'm attracted
to therefore to listening and reading
and of course the biggest problem right
now is that I'm so interested in these
events which hopefully will at some
point start to scale down deescalate in
the in Ukraine and one of my listeners
here gave me a link to Ukrainian
television station channel 5 and it's
fascinating because I listen to
Ukrainian and it sounds like Russian and
I think I should understand it and and
when I first listened I couldn't
understand hardly any and now the more I
listen the more I understand and I start
picking up words that actually are
similar to check like allez and or sip
instead of no and I don't know chelovek
whatever or sip is a person I think I
don't know you know and so I'm getting
used to the language so it's quite
interesting doing all that so with all
that stuff happening and listening to
the Russian stuff following the events
in Ukraine well I also had a
conversation with one of our tutors at
link Jenny and of course we have very
different opinions on on the events
there which doesn't prevent us from
being friends there's nothing wrong with
having different opinions he has a
different you know he has accesses
different news sources than I do I see
it differently he sees is different
that's fine and all right you know it's
interesting to be able to do all of that
in Korean I wish I excuse me in Russian
I wish I could do it in Korean and I
have to force myself and I will now
force myself although I'm gonna watch
the end of the third period of the
Calgary Vancouver game to stay with you
know Kim Jung Hwa's podcast because if I
get to the point you know at once I'm at
the tenth or so 12 15th episode I know
that my Korean will be a lot better and
I will continue the mistake kara you
know the characters the oh and the ah
but hopefully there again I will get
better I would get better faster if I
wrote but I'm not prepared to sacrifice
these other things that I find more
interesting in order to write but that's
for each person
to decide for themselves